how's it going red my name is Pierre
welcome back to bully it's night I think
[ __ ] it's night can we request it's
night yes we can let's roll yeah yes
you're not a [ __ ] you're beautiful just
kidding you're not yeah I just kidding
you are just kidding everything
I'm really tired today brothers I don't
know it's it's funny is usually when I'm
not tired you breath like pills it's
okay if you're tired I get it was like
I'm I'm not tired and then when I am
tired no one seems to give a [ __ ]
I'm not tired no whatever anyway that's
it's a lot of stars out there on the
mini-map do you ever watch the minimum
when I play I don't even know I
should've took in West ba [ __ ] all right
there's a quest here Tad's house sounds
a bit gay doesn't it
alright let's try it anyway I'm sorry I
don't know I'm dumb I'm dumb real dumb
hey kid hey kid please calm down calm
down
thank you
don't kiss really strong oh not you
Einstein not you so how did everything
work out with those eggs
never trust a rich kid too bad too bad
was it that jerk tad yeah you know his
parents right a party at my boss's house
right now nobody on it a revenge thing
now would be a good time I guess I'll
need some more eggs then ah yes you got
it
what's really great about Russell we've
got a house call to make oh so he had
rust on our team that's awesome Russ is
cart I got my cartoons of edge alright
shut up
we're gonna get my Vespa cuz I need that
[ __ ] Vespa I love you we're well Wow
polish up a bit no halibut how am I
supposed to wear a helmet with this PIN
pad are you serious
alright how the [ __ ] did we get over
there [ __ ] this thing Sears bad lay
poorly none goodly I found a G&G
collectible card I don't even know what
I'm doing with it I have nearly no
[ __ ] clue what's going on where watch
out kids oh that's my girlfriend
what's up dad or you going down
[ __ ] come here BAM
wham-bam what you are talk to the head
because the best-paying listen my my yep
oh shut the police [ __ ] the police [ __ ]
the police [ __ ] the Poli yes there is
[ __ ] yo I throw an egg through every
open window all right I can do that
hope the police gave up the police like
I whatever I don't know press to go into
aiming mode right in the face alright
good job Russ I don't care I'm but oh
[ __ ] there's a lot of windows all right
get him protect me Rosso good job
Russell hey what's your momma
all right there we go all right let's
take a rest man get out of here get out
of Tad's yard
sorry Russ
where's my vest can I take the car no
[ __ ]
where's vest back there you are ah what
are you doing I was dancing come on ah
we're writing my bond I don't want out
stop do what get on my Vespa come on
Russell
alright that was a pretty pointless
quest but hey we vetted let's take
another one oh hey mama what's up mama
yeah what's she doing either have a boob
shot ah [ __ ]
well sure where we going now
the Pierre
jumping boom I don't know why I made the
boom sound effect but hey it's pretty
badass
now alrighty then it should be something
over here
it's a lot of quests man a lot of credit
I don't even know anymore but stop
I love how best but never falls down no
what are you doing get on the quest
boxing challenge oh [ __ ] alright boxing
challenge Rosie ready for this so how do
I do it Pete
do what beat those rich kids in the
submission well what have you tried so
far
Renee more instruction gratuitous sadism
no no that's not gonna work we have to
do that kind of stuff at home no you
gotta beat one of them publicly you
gotta prove to them you're better than
their best man why don't you box that
dumb jerk Biff what who not bad Pete not
bad at all
alright see you around doc don't even
think about coming with me right how did
it go anyway teleporting Pete's his new
nickname
alright that's fights you and me buddy
hi Pam
step aside woman excuse me kids coming
fro all rights over here
step aside whoops whoops
oh yeah what I accepted the quest about
going on Best Buy
well shed what's happened you and me
Biff you and me what you a nipple trans
in the boxing may the best man win
and then you little trust fund fairies
well know what life is all about
anytime popper of course the best man
always wins me come on man words you can
clean my shoes I will let no way you
will lick my shoes all right here we go
these are usually pretty [ __ ]
straightforward you just click [ __ ]
five and [ __ ] Ron one fight oh [ __ ]
you can actually dogs and stop how does
it feel bit how does it feel how does it
feel bit oh yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
what's up what you gonna do me who's the
toughest me man me me losers me that's
right champion number one I killed the
best I will beat the rest I will [ __ ]
your head we got here that poor kid just
beat up [ __ ] he's our new champion what
he has been why you a champion come on
come on whoa
you disgust me
it takes more than victory to become a
champion breeding and nepotism and
snobbery
you filthy Democrat yes gentlemen are we
going to let some guttersnipe come in
and beat up our friend [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is done then what are we going to
do beat you back let it go
no I'm not even from together what the
[ __ ] oh you want to double fight night
now you have elliptical bus no hugs no
hugs get away from me
don't you see my haircut all right give
me got this stay back [ __ ] stay
back oh wow
stay back stay back now stop hogging May
I hate hugs boom all right [ __ ] smack
in time my fighting expertise will kill
you
how about that Oh Oh
how does it feel to die [ __ ]
and keeps fighting the bill states stop
yay I have that was a pretty fighting
machine what you smell [ __ ] out
die die you piece of [ __ ]
well oh you like that oh you like that
you fall through the stairs poor guy
I would've paid me right you should have
said that earlier I'm leveraging the
assets I have in you dope Fred
just shut up Darby here's some more
tactics for you
poor boy much Oh
oh okay
okay so you can't escape I got it oh
you're going down [ __ ]
Oh what is he doing no dance no okay
sorry got a little too excited who's the
boss now I can't hear you rich kids oh
the boss now my [ __ ] is badass that's
right me now you girls learn to play
nice you understand
instead of rose on his shirt that's so
cute love it
roses on the shirt that was awesome I
think I got your chapter rich so it will
surprise none of you to discover in a
future life he'll end up in Congress
[Laughter]
under control it's time to turn my
attention to their sworn enemies those
[ __ ] kids oh it's time for the
greasy balls
I love greens but what's never mind oh
you must be pretty proud of yourself you
taught those rich scum a lesson they're
rich weak bullies it was easy
they picked a fight with me and I showed
him who's boss I show you gonna show the
Levi oh maybe you'll show him as well
Gary's an even bigger problem he'll have
to wait hey what's this throwback want a
haircut a nice strong man to cuddle up
to who knows what come and ask for it
nobody tells Johnny anything Johnny
Vincent does the town well he doesn't
tell me what to do now beat it
[ __ ] you're causing an oil slick I
said he need your help man do I look
like a charity service you're gonna pay
for this pay for what I'm wrong with
this place everyone here are their needs
help wants to beat you up or both well
you know who Johnny Vince it is though
don't you know and I don't care you said
to the greaser click get friendly with
them many can help you get to Gary yeah
maybe tell you something Pete this place
blows tell me about it okay so that was
the new shot they're cool and it's Chris
that makes me happy hello hello little
al how did you say something
did you say it again say it say it say
it say no night laughs laughs I got your
nipple rising locked inside your nipple
is locked on target are you try to run I
can still got him though
still got all right it's starting you
[ __ ] love this game it gets better
and better
that's what's so awesome about it like
you should they went in there
games like this they usually introduce
what should I say like they usually
introduce everything about the gameplay
at once but here you get to know more
and more and more and more and I trip
like a mouse so it's cool I hope your
brothers are enjoying this well I think
you are alright little [ __ ] nope
don't believe it maybe we should go to
class I don't think I've ever went to
this class I want to go for two
photography class [ __ ] a - [ __ ]
well you know I haven't done enough all
right I'm a teacher I follow my
instructions precisely okay today yes I
suck at this I'm actually doing it today
I don't know why every other thank you
thank you so much I am carry my way
which
oh that's my new one hope you like it
say you like it alright so now I can
have more firecrackers good awesome I
don't know why all right here's one wait
and you quest I didn't mean all right
balls of snow why not hey kid what's up
Santa Claus I know okay then you want to
sit on my knee no in the balls luck
I know level one year I believe in
agreement with her posse of elves oh
it's really the next I'm getting treated
like a drunken fool I wonder why I don't
know the North Pole thinking why does it
sound like this okay man now you're kind
of creeping me out why does everyone say
that okay that's beautiful
I can't imagine I mean the other kids
was just abusing me close actually you
just like him
they're already funny hold on
which kids yeah which K those ones over
there the tough kids damn it
okay the rich kids fancy school like you
mollycoddling these boys
okay yeah that's me he was always the
prima donna where are these kids
they're my bought teleport I want to
teleporting but one of these days all
right let's just [ __ ] chill them
where are they well I can climb here
where are those kids what do I do now
get snow balls okay [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh
I see you [ __ ]
super focus bits the music is awesome
all right we gotta wait for him to come
back come here
[Music]
there we go male that little puke did it
what's up sign up yeah you're pretty
colors good luck with those reindeer
yeah good luck best dance ever
all right here we go finishing boom oh
yeah okay so that was it for today bros
hope you enjoyed like and favorite if
you did subscribe come bro today and
i'll see you next episode or biomech
[ __ ] love this game so far i'm glad
you boys like it a while anyway
[Music]